something's coming
[Music]
Jurassic world is in the past
[Music]
genetic power has been unleashed
I said we shut this whole thing down
we're not on an island anymore
witty pg-13 hello hello everybody I'm
Jeff Goldblum and she I'm so thrilled to
be back as dr. Ian Malcolm in the
brand-new movie Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom now I can't give too much away
but I have to warn you the movies quite
quite intense you're gonna see things
that you've never seen before
there are fearsome new dinosaurs that
look so real that you could that you
could touch them I mean not to you
should never touch a don't touch a
dinosaur in any case there are
incredible action sequences that are
gonna leave you breathless anyway don't
forget to book your tickets and I will
see you at the cinema thank you so much
high view I'm Bryce Dallas Howard I'm
Chris Pratt and we're here to give you a
look at our brand-new movie Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom we'd like to
introduce you to one of our co-stars now
don't worry this is not a real dinosaur
it's not one of the real ones is it good
because you know I nearly lost a hand
last time you can still see the bite
marks so this movie is bigger than ever
there are incredible new dinosaurs an
exploding volcano and dr. Ian Malcolm's
back so don't forget to book your
tickets now and as a special treat
here's a look at the latest trailer hi
Odeon I'm Bryce Dallas Howard I'm Chris
Pratt welcome to Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom
what was that
t-rex there are terrifying new dinosaurs
and exploding island and Jeff Goldblum
Spock
how did you do that what is it and with
the premier Club you'll get even more
roar for your dinosaur here's a look at
the new latest trailer to it again
[Music]
you